c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir la réponse de la guinée au
président en exercice de la cédéao
conakry a qualifié les propos d'omar ou
sissoko à un ballot de honte ce dernier
avait déclaré sur notre antenne la
veille de la tenue d'un sommet de
l'organisation ouest africaine que la
transition de trois ans en guinée était
inacceptable nous feront réagir ousmane
à gaoual diallo ministre et porte-parole
du gouvernement guinéen il est notre
invité ce soir la visite du président de
la transition guinéenne le colonel
mamadou doumbouya à bamako il a été reçu
sur le tarmac par le colonel a single
goïta une visite le jour anniversaire de
l'indépendance et quelques heures avant
la tenue du sommet de la cedeao à new
york les détails dans ce journal et puis
au burkina faso le colonel gilbert
dienderé condamné à 20 ans de prison un
verdict dans la sphère du meurtre du
leader syndical étudiant boukari d'abord
en 1990 le tribunal a également condamné
à de lourdes peines de prison deux
autres accusés nous serons à ouagadougou
dans ce journal
les militaires au pouvoir en guinée se
sont livrés à une charge très violente
contre le président en exercice de la
cedeao une réponse aux propos d'oumar
sissoko est mballo sur la durée de la
transition en guinée il avait déclaré
sur notre antenne que trois ans c'était
inacceptable je vous propose d'écouter
le colonel amara camara
n'est pas une émission de guignol ou du
télé réalité il s'agit de la sienne
diplomatiques entre des états
responsables qu'elle éclaire le respect
au sujet des sanctions pour les
proclamer
reprendront que ce n'est pas une
surprise venant du président moreau vous
l'aiderez temps ces propos qui
s'apparente à de l'arrogance contre
notre pays
et un diktat aux autres chefs déjà la
cedeao
la démarche du président mollo procède
d'une diabolisation du régime de la
transition en guinée
ça ne marchait la voir
et avec nous sur ce plateau sman gaoual
diallo ministre guinéen des postes et
télécommunications et de l'économie
numérique et porte parole du
gouvernement merci beaucoup d'être avec
une sur ce plateau alors je vais vous
faire également réagir sur le même sujet
on l'a entendu le colonel amara camara a
déclaré aussi entre autres un on a
entendu un extrême elle a déclaré que ce
dont il a été question dans les échanges
avec la cedeao sur la transition n'avait
rien à voir avec ce qu'avait déclaré
le président de la guinée-bissau oumar
sissoko un bal au président en exercice
de la cedeao que c'était mensonge et
quelle est votre version alors qu'est-ce
qu'il a été question concernant la
transition en guinée avec la cedeao que
d'avoir sur la forme il est
incompréhensible
le discours tenu par le président à
bissau guinee inacceptable dans le temps
est inacceptable dans la forme et c'est
quelque chose qu'il est inapproprié dans
les relations qui ont prévalu jusqu'à
maintenant entre la guinée et la cedeao
un médiateur a été désigné il a fait
deux voyages à conakry des travaux se
sont passées dans une ambiance bon
enfant avec un discours de vérité qui
lui a été apporté dans les conclusions
sont attendues
il est donc pas compréhensible que le
président en exercice qui en quelque
sorte n'est que le porte parole des
chefs de la faiblesse livrent à de
telles charges notamment en indiquant
que les réglages et des risques de
lourdes condamnations ça c'est quelque
chose d'inacceptable déjà que c'est pas
très honorable pour l'afrique de devoir
tenir pour l'afrique de l'ouest la
session de la conférence des surtaxes se
tiennent à new york l'afrique de l'ouest
un siège ça se tient dans le continent
africain dans les pays de la cemac
inimaginable de voir les chutes à
l'union européenne à marche de la céni
tenir leur session qui se tient à
bruxelles s'est passé pendant la fin mai
les propos sont inacceptables du point
de vue de la diplomatie et du respect
qui doit prévaloir lui même est venu à
conakry qui réussit avec tous les
honneurs il n'est donc pas
compréhensible qu'ils se livrent là le
stand et dieu sait ce que c'est la
deuxième fois que le président ballots
de façon unilatérale
charge la guinée l'attaqué parle de
façon vraiment
irrévérencieuse à l'égard des autorités
guinéennes et du respect que le peuple
de guinée leveaux alors ça reste confus
qu'est-ce qu'il a été question entre la
cedeao et la guinée concernant cette
transition de trois ans alors nous nous
fixons pas nous ne faisons pas de la
durée un dogme il a été question de dire
qu'est ce qui doit être fait pour que
les guinéens retrouve l'ordre normal des
choses
le 2010 à 2000 à la tradition de 2010
nous avons été contraints par la
communauté internationale de fixer une
période de la transition cela nous a
ramené un brûler des étapes et a donc
ressortir avec les mécanismes bancal ça
à plonger la guinée pendant dix ans dans
l'instabilité et les troubles qui ont
prévenu cette fois ci nous voulons
régler des problèmes définitivement la
question du fichier électoral c'est un
problème récurrent depuis 30 ans et
polluent l'atmosphère politique il faut
le régler comment le faire quelle durée
cela prendre c'est à ça que nous devons
nous entendre qu'est ce que doit
contenir la transition en termes de
fichier électoral en termes de noix en
termes d'institutions qui doivent être
mis en place avant qu'on parle de
processus électoral devant sortir donc
c'est du contenu d'internet est question
et de façon pédagogique nous avons
apporté les east fication qui
soutiennent la durée qui a été présentée
ici d'autres acteurs estiment que c'est
une durée qui est disproportionné
qu'il nous dise de pour quel contenu
alors justement vous parlez des lourdes
sanctions si cela devait arriver si le
sommet se tient ce jeudi avec le
décalage horaire il doit se tenir
bientôt dans quelques heures qu'est-ce
que exactement fera le président
doumbouya si il y à de lourdes sanctions
contre la guinée est ce qu'il est prêt à
revoir sa copie sur cette cette durée de
transition notons collaboration avec la
cedeao ne souffre d'aucune d'aucun doute
nous voulons travailler avec la cda
autres avec la communauté internationale
mais nos créations ne doivent pas faire
l'objet d'un diktat et ce n'est pas
quelqu'un qui tient l'info est derrière
le peuple de guinée pour le contraindre
à faire qu'auxerre tout le monde sait
que le guiner le peuple de guinée n'a
jamais agi sous la contrainte de qui que
ce soit que ce soit la cedeao que ce
soit l'union européenne ou ne la saisit
la guinée suivra son rythme et le
dirigeable qui elles poseront les actes
qu'il estime être bien pour la stabilité
la paix et l'unité de son pays et c'est
à cela que nous nous emploierons
lorsqu'il ya des demandes d'explication
qui sont formulées la guinée prête à
collaborer à apporter les réponses
appropriées
mais encore une fois cette relation doit
être une relation de respect mutuel et
de l'aso faire dans le bas de la
diplomatie et du respect que les peuples
ce blog se gare alors on va s'arrêter un
instant sur la plainte qui a été déposée
à paris le 8 septembre dernier par le fn
décès et des familles de victimes contre
le président du brouillard il est accusé
de complicité d'homicide et de torture
lors de manifestations juillet en août
dernier la plainte a été déposée donc le
disait le 8 septembre quelle est votre
réaction les cieux on a entendu dans ce
journal là les propos de des avocats
quelle est votre réaction à vous du coup
je pense que les avocats ils perdent un
peu la réalité ils ne parlent pas un
gouvernement qui est fermé ça c'est de
la plaisanterie des tribunaux guinéens
sont tout à fait disposés à recueillir
les plaintes de qui que ce soit pourquoi
venir sauf à l'idée de faire de la
communication les avocats disait que ce
n'était pas le cas que la justice
n'était pas libre que ce n'était pas
possible et c'est pour ça que cette
plainte avait été déposée ici à paris
parce qu'ils estiment que la justice et
la libre à paris et qu'elle est capable
de saisir d'un fait rappelle juste les
prend pas ce que ça se gagne ces deux
axes c'est une opération de com c'est
une plaisanterie qui n'a aucun sens et
je pense que si les juges et les avocats
là sont sérieux ils savent qu'ils
s'adressent à un état il s'adresse à des
politiques qui s'adresse à un pays pour
lequel jusqu'à preuve du contraire il
n'y a pas de l'obstruction il n'y a pas
d'obstacle à ce qu'ils déposent les
plaintes qu'il soit devant les tribunaux
guinée alors j'aimerais revenir sur sur
la restriction des libertés
que vous que vous reproche notamment une
partie de l'opposition le fn décès qui a
été dissous je le rappelle le billet le
8 août dernier et puis les interdictions
de manifester beaucoup vous accuse de
d'un côté lancé un dialogue et vous
allez en parler et de l'autre de
restreint de ses libertés de créer un
climat difficile pour un dialogue nous
voulons donner l'opportunité aux
guinéens de sortir des habitudes depuis
près de 20 ans le seul mode des changes
entre les acteurs politiques ceux qui
dirigent et ceux qui sont au pouvoir a
été ce rapport de force permanent dans
des rapports de défiance permanente et
cela a coûté énormément nous voulons
donner la chance aux guinéens de se
retrouver autour de la table d'essayer
de me d'inventer d'autres mécanismes de
regard de deux auditions de leurs
contradictions avant d'envisager
de marché ou d'autres formes de
protestation et aussi les difficultés le
contexte guinéen justifie largement que
les dispositions soient prises parce que
la crainte qu'il y avait elle s'est
révélée être là parce que nous craignons
effectivement d'être débordé et que cela
conduise à des pertes en vies humaines
qui ne se justifiait pas du tout
d'autant mieux que la place surtout que
la table du dialogue est ouverte la
place de ceux qui veulent dire quelque
chose pour l'avenir aline et toujours
elle est toujours là et ils sont prêts
s'ils sont prêts à venir apporter leur
contribution nous sommes disposés à les
écouter à échanger avec eux
une question aussi sur la situation
économique vous êtes en train
d'instaurer un dialogue il ya le la
situation politique qui reste compliqué
en guinée et il ya cette crise
économique est aussi lié à la la guerre
en ukraine qu elle la flambée des prix
comment vous comptez
réagir à cette crise économique pour
rassurer les guinéens il y a la
situation politique s'est pas qu'elles
les temps compliquée il ya certains qui
voudraient donner le sentiment que rien
à voir à ce pays le pays va brûle d'un
moment à l'autre ça c'est un sentiment
qu'on voudrait parce qu'il faut toujours
jeter l'anathème et le discrédit sur ce
qui se passe dans le pays ce n'est pas
la lecture qu'on a cantonné à l'intérêt
de pays c'est vrai la situation
d'ukraine a entraîné une crise notamment
sur les denrées de première nécessité
sur les pétrole etc mais l'appréciation
la bonne tenue du franc guinéen fait que
le taux de chance on n'est pas très la
nana patron n'a pas impacté très
négativement la hausse des prix et puis
le gouvernement guinéen a pris des
mesures économiques d'accompagnement
pour atténuer cette souffrance auprès
des populations et a eu aussi un certain
nombre dans billy les recettes fiscales
qui sont rentrés et qui sont en train
d'être utilisé à bon escient pour faire
en sorte que les guinéens vivent le
moins difficilement possible cette
situation qui a perturbé l'économie
mondiale depuis le début de la crise du
crédit alors restez avec nous on va on
va parler à présent de la visite du
président de la transition mamadou
doumbouya au mali il s'y est rendu le
jour anniversaire de l'indépendance du
pays ont fait le point avec marc faute
sur le tarmac de l'aéroport de bamako
l'avion présidentiel malien dépose le
président par intérim de digne mamadou
doumbouya est accueilli en grande pompe
par le dirigeant malien
les deux militaires putschistes profite
du 62e anniversaire de l'indépendance du
mali pour afficher leur unité guinée le
mali on dise c'est un poumon d'eux mêmes
dans un même corps donc pour moi il est
important
qu pour fêter l'indépendance du mali
avec me faire mal et hasard du
calendrier c'est aussi ce jour là que la
communauté économique des états
d'afrique de l'ouest doit se retrouver
en marge de l'assemblée générale de
l'onu à new york un sommet
extraordinaire consacré à la situation
en guinée et au mali la cedeao pourrait
ainsi annoncer de nouvelles sanctions
contre les militaires guinéens et leur
ambition de rester pendant trois ans à
la tête du pays avant de céder la place
à un gouvernement civil autres sujets au
coeur des discussions le sort des 46
militaires ivoiriens arrêtés le 10
juillet dernier à leur arrivée à bamako
des soldes a qualifiés de mercenaires
par la
côte d'ivoire assure de son côté qu'il
venait en mission pour l'onu et dénonce
une prise d'otages la cedeao indique que
dans ce dossier toutes les options sont
sur la table
lors qu'elle quelles sont vos relations
avec le mali des relations de bon
voisinage et et surtout le sujet
mutuelles
solidaires parce que vous êtes sont
aussi sous les sanctions en tout cas le
les menaces de sanctions de la cedeao
non pas du tout il faut se rappeler que
dans l'histoire le premier président
guinéen a dit un jour une phrase qui
resté célèbre que la guinée et le mali
sont des deux poumons d'un même corps
cela a été dit dans les années 60 70
ça reste encore vrai aujourd'hui les
peuples sont tellement imbriquées qu'il
était impossible pour les guinéens de
suivre les sanctions et la fermeture des
frontières du mali parce qu'il n'ya pas
d'accès pour leur paye pour le lait
malien eaux du port ça voulait dire a
confié ces populations est donc une
bonne partie de nos compatriotes le mali
est peuplée d'une population importante
de guinée et n'était pas pour qui si
possible de faire autrement que
d'exprimer notre solidarité
la meilleure des manières en ouvrant nos
peurs nos aéroports
ce rapprochement vous êtes déjà prochain
vous dites mais est-ce que ce ses liens
avec le mali c'est aussi une façon de
contrer d'éventuelles sanctions de la
cedeao non non non les sanctions
éventuelles la cedeao ne vont pas
altérer le fonctionnement la solidaire
des guinéens qui ont été solidaires
vis-à-vis de tous les pays en cours je
rappelle même la guinée-bissau de prise
d'armes barlow la guinée est leur base
arrière pendant la lutte pour leur
indépendance donc le premier président
d'ailleurs le de guinée-bissau monsieur
cabral est mort à conakry donc c'est
important de dire que cette vision
panafricaine au delà de toutes les
pesanteurs des sanctions bout qu'elle
vienne les guinéens sont toujours
prendre pas exprimer leur solidarité
vis-à-vis de leurs frères africains
aujourd'hui c'est une opportunité aussi
pour nous d'intégrer encore mieux nos
économies et de renforcer ces
interdépendances entre les pays et
pourquoi pas aller plus loin c'est
peut-être précurseur d'une nouvelle
forme de coopération dans l'espace de la
cedeao merci beaucoup monsieur ousmane
gaoual diallo ministre guinéen des
postes et télécommunications et de
l'économie numérique et porte parole du
gouvernement merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à nos questions merci beaucoup
et on continue donc à parler du sommet
de la cedeao qui se tient ce jeudi à new
york parmi les sujets sur la table et 46
soldats ivoiriens détenus au mali bamako
les accuse d'être des mercenaires le
président nigérien mohamed bazoum a
réagi sur cette affaire il était
interrogé par marc perelman et christ
quoi brouiller de rfi écouter
les propos à l'occasion de nos lignes
hall de la cdo du président ouattara
résonne encore d'améliorer il parle du
manie avec beaucoup d'affection
et il a été pour beaucoup dans la levée
des mesures
de sanctions prises par la cedeao alors
que vous étiez plutôt contre eux je
constate aujourd'hui
qu'il est payé
par l'ingratitude
de ceux qui ont tiré profit
de cette décision de levée de l'embargo
à laquelle le président ouattara avait
grandement contribué
il s'estime trahi oui je considère
qu'elle a été trahie moi aussi
le verdict dans le procès de
l'assassinât
1990 du leader syndical étudiant boukari
dabo au burkina faso le tribunal de
grande instance de ouagadougou a
condamné le général gilbert dienderé à
20 ans de prison la justice a également
condamné deux autres accusés à des
peines de prison le compte rendu avec
notre envoyé spécial à ouagadougou un
jeune au manioc
gilbert diendéré est condamné à 20 ans
de prison ferme plus un million de
francs cfa d'amendé le tribunal de
ouagadougou est allé encore plus loin
que les sept ans de prison demandée par
le procureur de la république
gilbert diendéré est reconnu coupable
dans la sphère de sept étudiants portés
disparus à la suite d'une manifestation
le 19 mai
1990 à l'époque où il dirigeait le
régiment de sécurité présidentielle qui
a enlevé puis torturé à mort l'étudiant
tout au long du procès il a plaidé non
coupable et a rejeté toute participation
à l'enlèvement de la victime l'avocat de
la partie civile maître prospère famara
n'a pas caché toute sa satisfaction faut
dire une réaction de satisfaction parce
que c'est l'un des dossiers
emblématiques
d'assassinât de burkina faso qui a duré
pendant 32 ans qui lui montrait l'un des
visages du côté eu des du visage de
l'ancien régime de blaise compaore met
donc c'était un grand soulagement
d'aboutir déjà un procès et une
condamnation des personnes inculpées
dans cette affaire deux autres éléments
du régiment de sécurité présidentielle
ont également été condamné
successivement à 10 et 30 ans de prison
il s'agit du colonel amadou bamba et de
goodbye magloire le général gilbert
diendiéré était déjà sous le coup d'une
condamnation de 20 ans de prison pour le
foot je manquais de 2015 hilaire
l'équipe à bled attentes à la sûreté de
l'état et meurtre
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique reste avec nous la faut
continuer sur france 24
[Musique]